فعوده سوريا هي بدايه للطريق وليس نهايه
للمسار بهذه الكلمات لخص امين وعام جامعه
الدول العربيه اهم قرارات مجلس الوزراء
الخارجيه العرب الذي اجتمع لمناقشه ملفات
سوريا والسودان وفلسطين وخلص الى تشكيل
لجنتي اتصال تضمان الجامعه والرياض
والقاهره لمواصله حلحله الامور
مصر بصفتها رئيس الجلسه اشارت الى مسؤوليه
الجميع عن تقدم المسار السوري في اطار
شروط وضعت في كل من جده وعمان تتعلق
بالعوده الامنه للاجئين وخطر الارهاب وضبط
الحدود لمنع تهريب المخدرات وغيرها ضروره
التفاعل الايجابي مع كل المكونات سواء
كانت سياسيه او انسانيه
وقضايا اخرى
ذاتها تاثير على المحيط الاقليمي وقضيه
تواجد القوات الاجنبيه دول مؤيده لقرار
عوده سوريا ابدت رضاها وان كان الجميع
يعلم انه مسار ليس بالسهل يجب ان نكون
واقعين مساله سوريه مساله معقده صحيح
مساله الى علاقه بالسياده السوريه وداخل
السوري ولكن
في الساحه السوريه الان هناك
دول مختلفه
مصالحها متداخله ومؤثره ايضا في ساحه
السوريه ليس
بقرار
لاقامه علاقات طبيعيه بين الدول العربيه
وسوريا هذا قرار سيادي لكل دوله على حدى
السودان خرج بما جاء من اجله لناحيه تاكيد
وزراء الخارجيه على سيادته ووحده اراضيه
والتعامل مع الازمه الحاليه باعتبارها
شانا داخليا نسمي القرارات التي اصدارها
المجلس الوزاري جامعه الدول العربيه اليوم
حيث اكدت على سياده السودان ووحدته وسلامه
اراضيه
وعدم التدخل في شؤون الداخليه عدد سوريا
الى الحاضنه العربيه مره اخرى وسواء كانت
ستسجل حضورا في قمه الرياض القادمه من
عدمه فان الامر الان منوط بدمشق كي تحقق
الشروط التي وضعتها لها الدول العربيه
لتيسير قرار العوده تامر نصرت العربيه
القاهره
لمتابعه المزيد
نروي البرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات